when you went up for your Oscar speech
I've always felt like I didn't belong
like I don't belong here I don't belong
in Hollywood did you I still feel like I
don't belong yeah um and I I mean I I
didn't there was there was no you know
it's about time that ever entered my
mind and I've had a complicated
relationship going back to Childhood
with the whole concept of awards for you
know Artistic Endeavors and and it was
basically everybody that I knew who
really understands the ins and outs of
of awards season and all of that I mean
everybody said dude there's no way it's
not going to be you so you know it was
it was like if they if they say and the
Oscar goes too and they don't say my
name I'm a schmuck you know because
because that's that's the expectation
right you know